quando eu fui a começar a preparar
essa é a apresentação há muito tempo
ah eu me lembrei da época em que eu era
especialista no assunto é nosso muito
específico é diagnóstico molecular é e
fiquei imaginando como seria se eu
falasse sobre isso e o que eu vou contar
pra vocês hoje é o que eu fiz na
transição da época que eu era um
especialista para o momento de hoje que
aconteceu nesse tempo e é uma história
longa começou no nos 86 eu estava no eu
vou falar terceiro colegial eu estou
familiarizado mais conhecer com essa
nomenclatura
minha mãe me incentivou a fazer um curso
de genética há uma semana nas férias de
janeiro de 86 na usp
a genética é uma disciplina que na época
era quente
o curso abordará um tema mais quente
ainda que a gente chamava naquele tempo
de engenharia genética alguns mais da
minha idade deve lembrar disso
morava em são paulo fiz a inscrição por
telefone e fui para ribeirão preto de
ônibus
lá chegando eu fui até a secretaria do
curso procurando a coordenadora me
apresentei porque eu ia seguir depois
para o alojamento dos estudantes seu
nome
eu falei meu nome ela em que você tá
fernando furlan no terceiro mas só o
terceiro ano de faculdade
bom se imagina um susto mas acabei
fazendo o curso eu vi uma espécie de
mascote da turma era formado em sua
maioria por pós graduandos em genética
voltando para são paulo comecei a fazer
um trabalho de iniciação científica no
departamento de zoologia do instituto de
biociências da usp a forma como cheguei
lá também é uma outra história
também era 86 o trabalho consistia em
realizar a fecundação a em vitro do
ouriço do mar em águas com diferentes
concentrações de detergentes objetivo
nosso era encontrar de r 50 que era
aquela concentração de detergente que
mataria 50% aa tem muita gente falando
assim com a cabeça
ótimo lataria 50% das larvas de ouriço
com esse trabalho ganhei na época um
concurso chamava o chamado cientista dos
cientistas do amanhã que era organizado
pelo idec
no ano seguinte estava na faculdade de
medicina
eu soube que o projeto tenha sido
selecionado para ser apresentado em uma
feira de ciências dos estados unidos
foi uma experiência incrível mas durant
e ele me ajudou muito essa experiência
me ajudou muito a aaa decidiu que eu
queria para a minha carreira eu queria
fazer pesquisa
mas durante essa viagem os professores
que nos acompanhavam matemático milton
observação meu respeito você pode
talentoso
eu levei uns 20 anos por entender que
aquilo que houve na época como um grande
elogio na verdade devia ser um alerta
eu não me distrair com as muitas coisas
que a que a vida nos traz bom na
faculdade medicina eu fiz iniciação
científica desde o primeiro ano desde os
primeiros meses não foi capaz em
diversos laboratórios mas uma das
disciplinas em hematologia a despertar o
interesse com maior intensidade então
não demorou muito para que eu me
entrosar se no grupo composto por
professores médicos contratados
residentes e isso ajudou a confirmar
minha escolha pela pela hematologia e
participava de projetos científicos
apresentava resultados em congressos
escrever relatórios da é publicada
trabalha seu era bolsista na época e
adorava passar tardes às vezes até noite
final de semana no laboratório mas vou
confessar uma coisa pela primeira pela
primeira vez não falo disso
se eu pudesse voltar no tempo eu acho
que eu teria aproveitado mais a
faculdade eu teria ido mais as
intermédias as atividades esportivas
bom até concluir o curso ainda durante a
residência médica começou o doutorado na
época era uma pesquisa bem nova' dor a
envolver a regulação da expressão do
gene do fator 8 da população
mas meu orientador se mudou para uma
outra instituição um grupo privado de
diagnósticos médicos e nessa mesma época
eu também recebi um convite pra
me mudar para uma outra universidade
pública que também tinha um grupo muito
forte na minha área e eu aceitei essa
oferta envolve a eu continuar a
pós-graduação trabalhar com com outras
linhas de pesquisa dentro desse grupo e
ser médico atuante na organização
eu mudei do orientador mudei de projetos
de doutorado agora uma pesquisa
vinculado ao genoma do câncer
um tempo depois numa época próxima
conclusão do doutorado
eu recebi um convite daquele meu
primeiro orientador vai também trabalhar
naquele grupo a de medicina privada e eu
aceitei é o ano 2000
o papel era ajudar na expansão da área
de diagnóstico molecular do grupo
olhando pra trás
hoje fica bem claro que o que acontecia
aqui foi a principal mudança na minha
carreira aqui pautaria todas as demais
eu deixava para trás aulas alunos da
faculdade de medicina residentes
plantões no pronto socorro no
transplante de medula na hemoterapia e à
pesquisa um dos principais centros do
país
deixava para trás da atividade que eu
adorava na qual é reconhecido algo que
algum tempo antes eu veria como abrir
mão do que eu sempre tive como certo
como a carreira que eu tinha planejado
seguir a vida nessa nova empresa no
entanto foi recheada de conquistas com o
meu grupo expandir no saara ea
notoriedade evidente no meio médico
além disso o status dos profissionais
como eu nessa empresa era muito grande e
consequentemente o poder de influência
no entorno
a decisão pela mudança sido difícil mas
não estava valendo a pena
no entanto a partir de 2005
aproximadamente a instituição começou um
processo acelerado de profissionalização
com o passar dos anos eu comecei a ser
exposto a ser exposto a temas novos
há como princípios básicos de gestão e
principalmente um tema que para mim era
bem novo que chamado governança
corporativa
basicamente a empresa incorporava os
seus quadros executivos profissionais
mudar o seu jeito de operar e deixava os
papéis de cada um mais claro
assim como as responsabilidades à
empresa visabeira a abertura do seu
capital na bolsa de valores
essa nova realidade começar a entregar
me achava que precisava entender aquele
mundo que não é mais o especialista em
técnicas moleculares específicas mas era
do gestor que criava condições que o
especialista trabalhar nesse contexto
também entende que o poder de influência
que esse gestor tinha uma organização
era muito maior
é claro que uma pessoa tão técnica como
eu era não se convencer ia facilmente da
importância dessa nova forma de conduzir
as coisas não dá pra dizer que eu também
vários tombos nessa época
no começo eu via as transformações na
empresa mas eu resistia muito a elas ter
entendido que se passava há naquele
contexto foi acima de tudo uma
oportunidade para refletir sobre a minha
carreira de uma forma diferente
mais uma vez eu tive ajuda profissional
para isso o momento de grande
transformação da empresa foi pra mim
essa oportunidade foi um laboratório no
novo dilema apresentado entre a opção de
vida de um especialista em diagnóstico
molecular e é de um gestor com maior
influência a nos anos da organização eu
recebi um convite para migrar em 2008
uma oportunidade na área de tecnologia
da informação e dentro da ati governança
eu não sabia do que se tratava
é eu aceitei como um desafio pessoal e
primeiro passo para a mudança e poucos
meses depois foi exposto a uma prova de
fogo e foi a pessoa indicada para
assumir também a área de projetos de ti
e em pouco tempo e fazer a gestão de uma
equipe de mais de 30 profissionais e ela
estava claro que eu poderia ser qualquer
coisa menos o especialista
bom pelo menos essa dúvida era uma que
não tinha e contava assim como a equipe
de especialistas que se reportavam a mim
em pouco tempo combinamos os papéis de
cada um o meu era de facilitar o
trabalho deles na organização
trabalhávamos com projetos estruturais
da empresa que visa a integração de
novas empresas adquiridas projetos de
educação internet
este sistema de atendimento ao cliente
os sistemas financeiros e comerciais e
mergulhei no mundo e chegamos a
implantar novas metodologias de gestão
de projetos com métodos ágeis
além de reforçar um legado excelente e
eu tinha recebido da área
foi uma época muito boa e naquela época
quando me perguntavam se eu não sentia
falta da medicina
eu sempre respondi 'não eu sinto que
estou adorando que eu faço e eu sempre
me lembrava que a decisão mais difícil é
aquela que tinha tomado lá atrás de
deixar a universidade de fato foi a
segunda grande mudança da da minha
carreira depois de sair da vida
acadêmica nessa época também deu um
passo importante
eu comecei o mba executivo internacional
que me ajudou muito a estrutura a
entender mais profundamente a gestão mas
não foi isso aí não foi só isso
a organização eo mercado passaram também
a me enxergar
no mais apenas como médico mas como um
profissional se formava como gestor e eu
não esqueço de uma das alas mais
importantes pra mim no curso e aqui a
aula versava sobre o poder e influência
nas organizações e que eu tento retratar
aqui
muito resumidamente eu entendi de uma
maneira quase que súbita que o poder de
influência que alguém tente que alguém
tem sobre o indivíduo é o resultado que
esse indivíduo consegue basicamente por
medo ou por ambição
por exemplo se a pessoa tem medo de
perder o emprego ela se submete a
trabalhar com uma coisa que ela não
gosta
o seu a pessoa muito ambiciosa ela pode
chegar a realizar coisas contrárias aos
seus valores para atender com ambição
você já viu esse filme a partir daí
ficava muito claro entender que o rumo
que a minha carreira tomaria seria
primordialmente consequência nas
decisões que eu tomava
talvez essa seja uma característica até
cultural da geração atual dos milênios
mas não era eu não achava que fosse da
minha geração foi como se eu conseguisse
entrar em encontrar uma explicação
técnica para movimentos passado que
tinha acontecido comigo mas muito mais
importante do que isso eu passei a
utilizar esse conceito para definir meus
próximos a
os profissionais assumindo o controle e
foi o que aconteceu a partir daí com
isso em mente concluindo cerca de dois
anos na uti
eu me transferi deixando mais uma vez
para trás um monte de amigos a por uma
área de negócios dentro da mesma empresa
era uma atividade completamente
diferente na qual passava a ser
responsável pelo crescimento e pelo
resultado financeiro da área
isso tudo aconteceu a partir de 2010 com
o crescimento da área ela se transformou
em diretoria e eu fui crescendo
profissionalmente em 2012
eu me tornei diretor executivo que é uma
espécie de vice presidente algumas
empresas e nesse período a área tornou a
essa área de negócio assumiu séu
aumentou significativamente ganhou novas
unidades e clientes
e eu me consolidei na posição aí eu
parei pra pensar puxa aquele médico
especialista em diagnóstico molecular e
ainda nessa época a organização
constituiu também uma joint venture com
uma outra empresa pra diagnósticos
odontológicos e eu também passei
acumulará a presidência daquele novo
negócio faz uma pausa aqui pra mencionar
algumas atividades associativas que eu
também serei o primeiro a me tornei
representante da delta em nome da minha
empresa no conselho da associação do
setor de medicina diagnóstica em
paralelo e assumir uma posição
inicialmente como membro do conselho
depois sherman da associação dos alunos
daquele mba internacional que eu fiz e
finalmente eu me tornei conselheiro
daquela do ambiente para diagnósticos
odontológicos por esse novo contexto eu
comecei a me preocupar em ter também um
preparo para essa função nova de
conselheiro embora fosse um executivo da
operação e eu fiz um curso específico
para isso em 2015
a idéia era que eu passasse a ocupar
essa posição em outras empresas de
mercado fazendo talvez uma nova
transição de carreira
esse era o plano e quando a gente
conversou sobre o ted a primeira vez era
isso que eu tinha em mente que tem o que
eu vou contar daqui a pouco é diferente
aí tem mais uma coisa nessa mesma época
eu recebi um convite pra começar a dar
aulas e orientar alunos do mestrado
profissional de uma escola importante de
negócios aqui em são paulo
curiosamente parece um retorno às minhas
origens
mas essa filiação também me colocou em
contato com jovens talentosos cheios de
idéias diferentes
aliás a gente tá vivendo uma época de
muita transformação dos negócios
tradicionais
a gente viu exemplos aqui hoje isso é
decorrente principalmente do rápido
avanço da tecnologia que permite troca
de informações de uma maneira
instantânea e muito abrangente também
com isso muitas empresas novas que os
jovens empreendedores à sua frente estão
surgindo e promete revolucionar a
maneira de resolver problemas comuns
nesse contexto acabou sendo natural que
também fosse envolvido na melhoria ou no
aconselhamento de alguns desses projetos
vivia bem até que quando foi minha
surpresa ao receber um convite para ser
membro do conselho da empresa
mas esse convite me deixava com
sentimentos ambíguos
ao mesmo tempo que significava uma
realização embora precoce de um plano
futuro significava também o término da
minha vida executiva da empresa atual
eu estava no auge bom vocês acham que eu
fiz é eu acabei aceitando
é isso aconteceu há poucos meses como
mencionei e ainda estou me organizando
essa nova trilha refletindo sobre isso
tudo será que a gente consegue pensar em
algumas conclusões em relação a essa
essas histórias eu separei há três
pontos principais o primeiro foi muito
importante eu tenho curiosidade para
entender um novo perceber que as
mudanças são constantes em todo lugar e
tentar a todo momento adaptar-me a elas
as pessoas mudam de ocupação as
carreiras de hoje são fluidas
isso pra mim é claro isso em segundo
lugar nunca é simples e não se ao passá
lo
foi preciso uma certa dose de coragem
para fazer uma escolha diferente do que
eu tinha planejado e recomeçar uma
trajetória profissional
logo no começo da migração para a gestão
um antigo chefe me desafiou os seus
pares têm pelo menos 15 anos de
experiência em gestão como você vai
lidar com isso gera o fato
mas finalmente eu acho o ponto mais
importante é estar preparado para
assumir riscos
talvez essa seja a característica que
mais ajuda uma pessoa ter domínio sobre
sua carreira porque a demonstrar apetite
por risco uma aura de desapego que se
estabelece faz com que magicamente o
controle das decisões de sua carreira
venha pra você muito obrigado
[Aplausos]